prochain les cérémonies maintenant très
émouvante à new york à washington et en
afghanistan etienne leenhardt ariel
mélange à l'heure précise où il ya six
mois deux avions de ligne percuté les
tours les plus célèbres de new york la
ville pendant quelques secondes ce matin
allée choisi de faire silence à la
mémoire des 2830 victime du world trade
center dans la capitale américaine
george bush avait lui invité pour une
cérémonie du souvenir les ambassadeurs
de 150 nation histoire de montrer que
dans son combat contre oussama ben laden
l'amérique n'était pas seul et qu'elle
n'allait d'ailleurs pas limiter sa
guerre contre le terrorisme aux seules
frontières de l'afghanistan
chaque terroriste doit devenir un
fugitif où qu'ils se trouvent sans
refuge pour s'organiser ou s'installer
non sans endroit pour se cacher sans
soutien d'aucun gouvernement
en attendant sur le plan militaire c'est
encore l'afghanistan qui retient
l'attention aujourd'hui le dispositif de
l'opération anaconda a été allégé pour
permettre à plusieurs centaines de
soldats de récupérer d intenses combats
de la semaine dernière le 11 septembre
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes ici en afghanistan
mais quand on vous tire dessus vous ne
pensez pas à sa séquence et à la seconde
qui vient selon les estimations
américaines 200 opposants seraient
encore cachés dans les grottes au dessus
de garde aise et les en déloger ne sera
pas chose facile